what's the matter Bobby don't feel so
good you don't look so good either
but that's just cuz he ugly hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome to what may be the last new
surgery in the bunch which is the teeth
surgery which first means that I need to
get this mask off of his face I don't
know why they decided that this was a
new mechanic because I seem to just be
stabbing him in the jugular and not
really doing what I intend to do you
okay Bob you okay with this right I am
right on that why is this there we go
first step complete well that may have
been the hardest part of it nope this is
gonna be the hardest how is his heart
flat lighting already I'm just stabbing
him in the jaw I'm not even close to his
heart
oh no we're sorry ma'am while we were
replacing your husband's teeth he died
of heart failure
don't ask how just cut the damn thing
there we go okay you need to calm them
down so here have some nice gas well
I'll get my weird bag oh god where did
it go there we go yeah sure go go go
any minute now gonna get it I'm gonna
get it you relax Bob I got this I got
this unlock I am a professional at
cutting the ding-dong damn elastic it's
right on target Wow
I'm using the Force and everything I
even have my guidance system turned on
use damn for Annie's dying again God
when will this guy stop dying on me well
who would have thought that I needed a
defibrillator prepped and ready Oh oh no
he's got a negative heart rate how does
it even make sense clear
sorry ma'am your husband's heart stopped
ten times during the surgery it was just
the damnedest thing what a drill will be
appropriate for this scenario oh okay
yeah almost got it yeah
oh well that might be obviously died the
fountain of bone and blood may be an
indication oh through your way through
angry
I see how Ubu changed up the location of
your tooth fizz each time no pool just
the gentlest of boobs it would flip huh
almost got it
hang on a little bit Oh your heart
stopped
oh no clear right on the teeth got it
saved another one doctor you're such a
genius
shut up nurse I know it Wow I need to do
dr. glass they're gonna swallow that
poop there maybe I could try to be a bit
more precise about this and just like
yes get the one that I need no but
knocked out the wrong one got the wrong
one again keep knocking out the wrong
ones this guy seems to be bleeding but
oh god not again jeez Bob I'm not okay I
threw those away because obviously I
don't need them anymore come on come on
there we go okay now since I lost my
things I'm not gonna let you die on me
and I'm actually gonna get you some
niceness
so what tooth did I take out a good bite
a better wall opened a box and he died
well it's gonna look at you Bob well
you're still ugly but I think I can do
something about those teeth over there
with the correct to do
Oh who's right on top Oh heart stop he
was just poking at his teeth oh this is
not gonna make it is it hmm oh that was
a close one
I almost lost another one just like I
did back in Grenada Grenada I don't know
there was a lot of grenades I don't
really remember it this one looks like a
precision poker so if I precision Lee
poke it it should work right oh stop oh
goodness what is these teeth directly
related to the heart
I'll just melt it away melt the way that
bone
I melt the whale bone melt it away on
the pounds off fat along with the rest
of your face just melt away but 3290
time payments of thirty seven eighty
four you two can have a face as pretty
as this whoa loses no garage shop I'm
gonna get this no matter what you stop
flapping your gums for two seconds or
you're gonna be nothing but gums if
you're listening to what I'm laying down
what got smash oh that probably didn't
feel too good
well that was too bad
and much like better news oh I'm a
dentist right not a doctor
I don't think I'm a doctor at this point
anymore shut up baby I know I'll see you
in the operating room cause there's so
much bleeding
how can you bleed through that much on
your gums oh it's gone I need to stop
that bleeding
Boop bit bit stop stop stop stop hey
stop wait stop it stop that bleeding
stop that right now
Oh Mike Reinders horrible okay now this
may seem like a bad idea but bear with
me it probably is much worse than you
think okay his heart stopped gotta keep
that going back up that's not good Boop
oh no just one take it take my
electricity coppenole do good cup not
effective effective it disturbing me
there's some results there we go that
doesn't hurt too bad I'm supposed to you
this way you get seen out my mouth Oh
whoopsies now Bob you frisky makes you
you need to stop that right now
everything over the boat
come on hit where I'm aiming boop boop
boop what these are actually weak teeth
why do they need to come out because
they seem to be perfectly strong to me
and my hammers gone don't you sass me
boy don't you sass me and you're dying
well too late now open your mouth and
get ready for my saw whoa whoa what what
would I do what happened what happened
what did I do oh did I touch that oh I
get it
whoa whoa what is happening oh I
probably shouldn't pick up this drill
should I happened oh my goodness well
and and my oh god this is kind of not
correct oh god no no no no please end
I've gotten every single tooth oh my god
Oh Oh get the bottom one oh don't let
him die oh come on Bob you can suffer
through a little more Oh God
okay don't let his heart go too low that
last one come on
oh he's gonna die come on did I get it I
didn't get it oh come on get out of
there I think it's gone is it gone is it
gone
I think it's gone along with everything
else I think it's gone now it's just a
matter of placing the teeth huh huh yeah
whoo all right no no no no okay okay
okay okay oh you're gonna have the best
smile when I'm done with you can I get
the other particulates out of your mouth
or you just got a cape
thrashing I'm about a bit okay you you
ate him okay good I don't know if I have
enough teeth for this run out of teeth
come on get in there oh no no not there
not there not there not there that's the
right spot I get in get in
it's on your face and all over the place
is not going where it's supposed to be
damn it okay that's good enough for me I
don't know how I did it but I did that
was literally the hardest surgery I've
ever done I think that's so many times
why did he keep dying Oh God
anyway there you go I think that's all
the new surgeries in certain simulator I
believe there may be something else but
I'm gonna go look for it
um either way if you guys have something
else that you want me to do on this
please let me know in the comments below
if you want to see more of this you
gotta let me know so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos I've done and as always
I will see you
[Music]